I discovered that something that was
unimaginable just a few years ago is
happening now Chinese and American
scientists collaborating to secure
nuclear materials uranium from the far
corners of the globe I'm rich stone
I'm the international news editor at
science magazine and my story for the
Pulitzer Center is about Chinese and
American scientists working together to
save the world and this is really part
of my beat at science magazine I have a
rather unusual beat it's weapons of mass
destruction and particularly difficult
countries to report from such such as
Iran and North Korea even though I lived
in China for five years I never got
permission to go to China's nuclear
weapons design laboratories as real
object of frustration for me and I
thought well how can i nibble at the
edges of the story 20 years ago there
was a report in the US Congress about
Chinese spine in the nuclear complex it
was allegations of spine that china
vehemently denied but because of that
report American scientists had been
barred from the Chinese Academy of
Engineering physics there's been no
collaboration practically speaking for
the past 20 years
so the fact that they're getting
together now is pretty significant so
for the story I reported from Beijing
and from Accra Ghana I visited a new
center for excellence in nuclear
security that the US and the Chinese
work together to establish pretty
amazing complex they have a bunker where
nuclear materials special nuclear
materials are stored I got to go inside
the bunker with the scientists there and
the first thing you notice going in the
razor wire curlicues of razor wire
hanging from the ceiling and the
scientists pointed to a yellow line just
a few inches from from my feet and I
said if you step past that line the
razor wire falls down on you he was
joking it wouldn't fall down on you but
what happens with the razor wire is it's
lowered to the floor
when staff are not there at an operating
nuclear facility storing nuclear
materials like this it's one measure to
slow any potential nuclear smugglers so
ever since 9/11 the US government has
been very concerned about securing loose
nukes
first of all nuclear weapons and also
any nuclear materials in countries that
are not one of the nuclear weapon states
and there's a lot of this nuclear
material out there so the US has worked
throughout Eastern Europe to move out
highly enriched uranium there are
smaller amounts that are also scattered
around the globe including
at research reactors that China produced
in the 1980s and 1990s and shipped to
five countries it's a very unusual kind
of research reactor it's called a
miniature neutron source reactor and
these reactors are in Ghana Nigeria Iran
Pakistan and Syria it's not really
necessary at this point to have that
kind of weapons usable a nuclear fuel
the reason that is not necessary now is
that Chinese and American scientists
work together for ten years on a project
to redesign the reactor core of the
miniature neutron source reactor to
convert it to run on low enriched
uranium which cannot be used for a
nuclear weapon unless it's further
enriched and that's not easy to do and
so Ghana was the first reactor outside
China to be converted I was in Ghana
when the new core was brought in and
installed into the reactor the highly
enriched uranium core had already been
taken out but when I visited it had not
left the country yet and one of the
nuclear regulators from Ghana remarked
when we passed by it somewhat
mysteriously he said there's a little
God under there
that's like what do you mean and he
whispered to me that's it that's the old
core so it was not something that they
wanted to have lying around
finally last month in August the plane
took the uranium back to China now the
Chinese and Americans are going to work
together in the next conversion which is
going to be in Nigeria this coming
spring people hope that this will lead
to more cooperation among the nuclear
weapons scientists
you